byrne ex leader stories oggi faremo una
cosa epica innanzitutto vi faccio vedere
come diventate un mega flop islands
gigantesco dentro la cucina perché è
sanissimo adesso e poi andremo a
trasformarlo in un mega anzi gaisberg
guardate un po come è diventato e super
strano ho chiesto come è diventato time
dove lei messo è sempre 4 guardate un po
come si solidificato che strano allora
questa parte qua e super dura e si
vedono tutti i glitter sopra assurdo non
sembra colla sembra plastica dura poi
quasi una parte tutta corsa lo stesso
dura e durissimo dopo il brusco scopo
carlo il colore è rimasto più o meno lo
stesso forse se scurito un po poi qua
abbiamo delle bolle sun è riuscita
scoppiarle cinema è durissimo un pochino
più morbido quale basta più la
consistenza dello slam però qua a storno
riesco non riesco a bucarlo è possibile
guardate un po in pratica si è creata la
crosta in superficie oddio o mio dio
questo è veramente dovremo più assurdo
che abbia mai fatto o che abbia una mia
collezione cioè vabbè ma cielo tra il
normale che è un po appiccicoso però
appiccicoso
oddio se guardate attenzione io destro
fa scoperto chi vuole un prezzo di sla
in modo gigante sono perfetto però
sembra qualcosa di un porco l'ho imposto
io non riesco proprio vorrei bucarlo ma
non ce la faccio tiriamo l'acqua quindi
sotto è rimasto tutto lo slime fresco un
altro pezzo di addio sembrano davvero di
polmonare mi consenso
[Musica]
che prima di trasformare brin iceberg
klein corrieri mischiano bene però mi sa
che è meglio lasciarlo così mi sa che
ormai è troppo tardi
no questa particolare veramente
durissima dove scrive che spezzarla
impossibile colorarlo un po di blu anche
non so come pare però se così duro
metto comunque un po di coloranti giu e
veniamo allora vediamo se lo slime
registra anche alle forbici
andiamo a adesso si rompono le forbici
tantissima 80 ma comprare la piscinetta
sotto chi è vero sto ancora tutto che si
no vabbè assurdo quanto è duro sono
riuscito a tagliarlo ma è super spesso
senti il rumore
[Musica]
oddio ma il creato 1 st vacca tipo
guarda adesso esce rileva il nostro 11
si chiama italia no vabbè guarda giù si
crea una tasca c'è qualcosa qua dentro
e veramente la vostra e dunque
come si chiamano italiano da sottosopra
immagina soprattutto soprattutto di
persone commercio tra la mamma mamma
mamma mia
io non so se devo continuare che
facciano rivolto a sandown non saprei
ho paura che si rovini ancora di più un
parte c'è poco perderemo anche le
forbici quel risucchiato nuovo slime ma
possiamo dare così sembra una carcassa
di animale
va beh diciamo che non puntino perché
con questo colore vi fa molto tempo
torniamo colorano di blu con timore
diventa carica adesso diventa verde non
è giusto sopra
mi sembra di dipingere a questi pezzi
diventeranno pensi mi piaccio
dell'iceberg slime super solidi quindi
però ancora più rumori una volta che
andremo a staccarlo con il martello
spaccheremo comportati così una cosa che
diventa super turo va beh direi di
iniziare con la schiuma da barba lo so
che non ambani cena scherzo ma riteniamo
che la prima con muretto
che sto formando una torta tv un altro
famoso particolare oddio come diventerà
del 12 maggio
no ma che ca in piedi verso di che cosa
vorrebbe venderlo
secondo me credo una puntata ma non lo è
[Musica]
il premier indicando cosa più divertente
ma è anche molto faticoso non vende
dischi ma la barba ai e te lo devi
tenere in diagonale così diamo se ci
riesco
no il veneto è veramente strano
mischiare così tanta schiuma
oddio sono entrato dovrebbe prima magari
troppo amore
i ragazzi abbiamo fatto per notte in
quanta schifo da barba e anche inventato
celestino diciamo poi questa parte farlo
lasciata così senza mischiarla speriamo
che vi sono i debiti tanto e ora
facciamo un trend traverso è un viaggio
nel tempo e ci ritroviamo a contro lo
stand sarà duro pronti a martellarlo a
martellarlo 32 ora è così con sterili
abbiamo aspettato due o tre settimane
quanto abbiamo affrettato cielo tre
settimane un sacco di tempo è infatti
come potete vedere guardate un po come è
diventato è stranissimo
ho aspettato di tempo possibile perché
un avo cassi solidificasse il più
possibile però alcune parti non si sono
solidificate molto la scrivo da barba in
superficie non è molto dura o rigida
comunque però quella sotto molto infatti
andremo spaccarla con il portello
però non so perché quella che è rimasto
sopra in superficie non si è
solidificata molto penso perché non era
ben mischiata con la colla comunque
siete curiosi di vedere cosa succede ora
che è buco lo slime con il martello mi
raccomando meno fatto la casa che però
fa
pericolosissimo quindi lasciati per
passare queste cose e quindi queste
iceberg e flavio tesco dentro una fissi
cosa ne pensate vi piace quello che il
colore blu abbia preso un po anche sotto
ma ora lo vedremo assieme perché ora
andiamo a sfondarlo con il martello
adesso thun be like se volete che
passano triturare i giganti se fosse
leader aggiunge in 15 milioni extra una
giusta incidente a vostra scelta
scrivete nei commenti
ecco qua il mio martello che poi è
uscito comunque dove il centro dall auto
motorini qua attenta alla poppa del
tavolo infatti o con un po di paura
allora andiamo andiamo andiamo via
il primo corpo non è bastato il martello
riportato come impossibile talmente
letteralmente di gomma che non lo sfonda
si no forse non sono basse
una forte io proviamo fa al centro di
gomma o no ma come perché dispone lo
slime che ha sporcato il martello
particolare il barcone con te sporco ora
si sfonda il tavolo dai piega ma non si
spezza mandarti tutti sfotto diventato
immune anche il martello io aspetto
farrow ha fatto la crosta sopra sotto e
rimasto morbido entra
wow
fa impressione
possibile che non riesco a sfondarle un
nuovo e potente che dovrei usare un
martello appunta questo slime è immune
diventato fortissimo nella schiuma per
forza la sfonderà la scuola 321 bene
oggi ho sentito il rumore tipo che si fa
8 ho sfondato la crosta e ora è tutto
liquido la sotto lo vedete che si muove
di orari minuto incastrato troviamo qua
adesso si pose il buco quindi quello più
morbido era meno immune troviamo qua no
di gomma cioè assurdo certe lasciate uno
slam per così tanto tempo diventa
durissimo che dite proviamo con le mani
[Musica]
aumentati qua è sì un morbido lo slime
slime
allora contempo strano mettere le mani
nel sacco di grande di qua e ancora
slide vedi ed era anche rischiato con il
colorante blu quindi decisamente questo
è rimasto slime è anche morbido questo
adesso è passato così tanto tempo e
appiccicoso che strano invece quando
l'hai lambert wine un dio c'è e
diventato veramente ci può nascondere le
cose la denso e turismo si buca nessun
modo mio dio
8 addio dopo vostro nuovo bella swan che
stava sotto punti e di un altro colore
qua sotto
va bene fate un palmare maranello sta
venendo risucchiato questa slide
malefico che stampando un martello sta
mangiando e poi devo lui qua c'è una
trama come sempre perché guarda qua
molto più bello dall'altro lato guarda
il nostro morbido glitterato cioè a
girarlo anche qua oggi sembra una cosa
strana è rimasto morbido lo slime lo
stesso ci danno tutto che strano fare
tipo il rumore su merino slann così
grosso
ora il martello avevano mangiato gallot
live
appoggiamo povero modello che abbiamo
fatto finora il nostro se con tutte le
mie forze perché è molto più bello sotto
[Musica]
polpo paul pong ceva queste cose più
scure per col mio numero del colorante
blu
oddio veramente nello slang strano che
abbia mai fatto è rimasto altro slime
faccia tutta la schiuma
cioè assurdo questo è rimasto slang come
se fosse appena fatto e appiccicoso cioè
assurdo che si solidifica poco piccolo e
twitter sono tutti sotto allora ora
prova dati una martellata da questa
posizione forte tutti ora lo sta
mangiando lo sfruttare succhiando ottici
notte lo slime sabbie mobili
l'ho fatto risucchiare l'acqua non esce
sulla validità dello slam sul martello
resistentissimo sempre iceberg gigante
stranissimo da mille consistente la
saville light e volete che faccia altri
plame giganteschi e fatemi sapere nei
commenti che altre sale giochi
attrezzato lessi che facciamo leva non
vi lascio qua 4 castelliri strumenti
cardine delle mie accettati nel mio tre
falle nell'eccezionale con la ruota
video divertenti cliccate su quella di
vita buona di pianezza ciao